Take this pen, and this bit of paper.
Peg it on here.
What's happening?
It's going bigger! And what else is happening?
It's gone blue!
Yeah it's gone blue.
Is there anything else apart form the blue you can see?
Black! I can see light pink.
So we started off with a black dot, and the water's gone through the black dot.
What do you think that means that we're now seeing these different colours?
That the blue is separating from the black and the pink is separating from the black.
Very good Samantha!
I've got some strips of paper here, and we've got some different pens.
What do you think might happen?
It'll turn another colour?
Would you like to try? Yeah!
Don't put the dot in the water,
just dip the end of the paper in. That's it! Then peg it over the top.
Shall we watch and see what happens to the colours?
You both used different pens, didn't you?
Mine is blacker.
Mine is more blue.
And mine isn't turning any colour.
It's not is it? There's a wee bit of bluey-green.
So what does that tell you about these pens? Do you think these pens were made...
Differently!
How can you tell it's not the same black ink? Because it's different colours and patterns.
This process of separating a sample of inks out into its constituent colours
is known as chromatography. This literally means coloured writing.
It works with ordinary water,
but if you'd like to try adding about a tenth of the volume in salt
you can get better results depending on
the inks that you use.
I've used ordinary kitchen roll, but you can also try using different types of paper,
such as coffee filter papers or even
loo roll, so long as it'll absorb the water.
Because different coloured dyes travel at different speeds in the liquid,
an ink that is made up of different dyes, like the black in that I've used,
can be separated out into its constituent colours.
I've got a puzzle for both of you:
I've got your initials on these bits of paper,
but we don't know which pen wrote them. How do you think we could figure that out?
By writing all the pens on the top? That's one way...
They'll both have different colours
when the water touches them!
Yes! So how will that help us to figure out which pen it is?
Because we've used all the black pens. If one looks exactly like one of those,
we know which pen was used. Yes!
Do you think they'll all look the same when they're dry?
This one looks like that one!
We've had loads of fun doing this experiment. If you'd like to learn more about chromatography,
don't forgot to log on to the website and download our worksheet.
We'd love to see your photographs and videos of you doing this activity too,
And don't forget to subscribe for more great experiments